На минулому тижні того самого дня коли
ми дізналися про
вбивство про страту азовців у оленівці в
артерії
єдиного телемарафону була гумористична
програма Так звана барахтар токс якого
виробляє Студія 95 квартал цій програмі
вони виклали інтерв'ю видали інтерв'ю
такого пана поворознюка
ці ролик на
каналі вже має 200 тисяч переглядів де
пан павознюк стверджує що Порошенко
вкрав його гроші 30 мільйонів
і до пана поворознюка як такого нема
питань він не там мета особа якої нам
цікаво було б виясняти чому він так
стверджує він не та фігура але ми
обурені і Порошенко обурений ми як його
адвокати висловлюємо його позицію тим що
на державних грошей на гроші податків
податків
вибиваються ну фактично людей примушують
дивитися такий лайно тому ми оголошуємо
що сьогодні ми подаємо кілька запитів
Ігор головані коли розкаже про ці запити
і я закінчу цю думку і Ігор продовжить
метою яких є з'ясувати що взагалі
відбувається чим займається Студія 95
Квартал на які гроші
ці чи з бюджету державного бюджету чи з
бюджету каналу 1+1 в слові якого була ця
програма їм сплачують за розповсюдження
І чи це має відношення до якихось
офшорних компаній бо ми не впевнений хто
власник цього цього YouTube каналу
після того як ми це є за своєму для себе
ми будемо приймати рішення про те чи
подавати позов і саме до кого я Нагадую
що
було б ну було б смішно судитись з
поворознюком нас цікавить не він нас
цікавить виключно
то на яких підставах і і за чи за чиї
кошти відбуваються
відбувається Ця продукція
телемарафону хотілося б додати що Ну
наприклад мене Важко назвати там
глядачем Квартал 95 але ось враження
складається таке що ну
повномасштабних вторгнення велика
трагедія війна вона абсолютно не змінила
гумор цих
творчих персонажів Вони все ще
займаються небо допомогою армією в
боротьбі за агресором А вишукуванням у
різних нетрях різних сумнівних
персонажів які можуть щось таке погане
ляпнути про Петра Порошенка і потім цей
непотріб Вони якось просовують за цієюсь
допомогою ви ефіри е-е спільних
марафонів які Наскільки нам відомо
транслюються за державні кошти Отже наше
завдання зараз ми направили відповідні
адвокатський запити щоб з'ясувати
двоє авторами цього якщо можна так
висловитися аудіовізуального твору з
участю відомого без волосся персонажа і
іншого я не пам'ятаю чи з волоссям чи ні
щоб з'ясувати хто є режисером хто є
оператором хто є сценаристом цього
всього що змушують людей дивитися на
спільному Марафоні для чого це робиться
і головне яким чином кошти платників
податків якщо це так витрачаються на як
вже правильно було сказано на таке лайно
Я думаю що зараз якраз в той час коли ця
історія має стати відкритою прозорою і
коли ми повинні всі розуміти хто
намагається підзаробити на нашій
загальнонаціональній трагедії так якщо
додому вибачаюся я що додам В нас дуже
цікаві позиції Національної Ради з
питань телебачення що вони якою саме
головне думки про цю ситуацію і ми
бачимо що
власник цього YouTube каналу Студія 95
квартал Ми наразі не знаємо Хто це бо є
кілька організацій у реєстрі який
називаються 195 квартал Ми не знаємо чи
на одну з них записано власник цього
YouTube каналу чи ні але ми вже бачимо
що вони починають повзати бо той ролик
який я згадував які протягом всіх
вихідних називався
скільки грошей Порошенко вкрав
поворознюка він зараз називається щось
там на штат що Поворозник запитає в
Зеленського після перемоги тобто вони
розуміють ці люди які би вони не були що
вони припустилися ну Великого скоттства
і вони вже пробують
пробують якось уникнути відповідальності
за на те що відбувається ми спробуємо
по-перше з'ясувати цю ситуацію якщо
будуть підстави юридично
а запобігти тому щоб вони цю
відповідальність фактично уникнути